i'll be on another honest thing i want
to say to you is that i've had um
desires of
using for some reason really which drug
weed
i have a strong desire to do it it seems
like you're going through just like a
feeling of like
like you're trying to you're not happy
like there's something i just feel lost
a little bit really yeah
do you feel like you have to always stay
sober your whole life is there a
pressure of that of that feeling i feel
like if i if i
i'm afraid that if i do go back i'll
have to do all the [ __ ] i did two years
ago which is like get shipped away
somewhere and inevitably you know it'll
be a crisis you know and i don't want
the crisis that's why i haven't done it
you know what i mean but i was um in
brooklyn monday and i was at a
restaurant
and the guy goes do you want a drink
and i this has never happened before in
my life i went i looked at the alcohol
drink menu
and i was like which one should i get
right and for some reason i want i'll
just have a diet coke
then he goes we don't have those oh what
is this guy right right and then he goes
um but we make our own
kind of soda-y drink
so i was like give me that then right
but i remember
almost making the decision to do it but
i didn't damn
i think partly because i had to shoot no
that was
i had already shot so yeah i think yeah
i would have done it i think
yeah do you think like can you like it
do you think like you just retire like
you're just
the world feels boring like do you feel
like you're angry like do you notice any
feelings about it no i just feel like
because of the pandemic and stuff that
like it's not truly over it people
pretend like it is but something's
different i feel like it's hitting me
now yeah like
during the last year i was fine i was
fine i was cruising i was cruising and
now
my head's completely [ __ ] in ways that
i didn't think could get there like i
hear him and i are going through
something similar where i'm like
i don't know what it is but i feel
something like shifting
and cracking inside me yeah but i think
it's a social it's a society thing i
agree with you i agree i do think i
think a lot of people are having to tell
a lot of people are going through a lot
i had six friends that's why my one of
my whole things about the pandemic has
been like all the separation is not good
like i've had six friends that overdosed
and died that i knew like six friends
right wow deceased gone
during this whole thing i mean we had
eric myers that comedian
god i mean that's
it all feels fake it all feels like
everybody and when things start back
everything's going to turn the key and
we'll be right back and and i never got
to talk about eric and i want to talk
about him now i never was able when he
died i never talked about him
and uh um i just want to say that
eric myers was one of those guys i
remember being in dc
and this is years ago and and they go
this is your opener and this guy the
skinny white kid comes in
and just shy
yeah and i was like he didn't even seem
like a comic guy he looked like a carny
yeah he did look like cardinal right he
ran a couple snowball stamps
not well yeah yeah
and i go go he and once i saw him up i
got scared because i go oh [ __ ] this
guy's legit
like a killer yeah and every time i'd
see him perform he would kill but then
sometimes i would see him in the streets
and he was a homeless person yeah like
one time he had
i was at the store during the day
picking up a check and the manager goes
i think eric myers is outside and i went
outside he was wearing no shoes he was
wearing yellow pajama pants right and he
had any they were yellow but i but there
was blood
coming through the knees
so they were stained in there right he
had a gash on his head
but you know
it felt like the blood had coagulated on
his head and dried so it was like a
blood knot like a kill bill extra almost
yeah yeah and he had right down and he
was shaking he was like oh i need money
and i go and i and i know being a sober
guy
i shouldn't give him money but i think i
gave him like 300 to get a hotel room
and some food and stuff and then he
would get sober again he would look
great you'd see him perform and then
one day he just i get a call johnny
sanchez called me and said eric died
and i don't even know how he died i
think i heard he got run over by a truck
or something
big truck bus
did a bus really run him over yeah how
could have been a truck but how does a
bus run you over he got off i know he
got off of a bus and got hit by a truck
is what happened
he got off a bus i think he got this all
speculation as well i heard that he got
into an argument on a bus or didn't want
to be on a bus anymore and i frequented
greyhound and i get it you know what i'm
saying there's always somebody showing
you their dick somebody's selling you
drugs that you've never even heard of
you know
and you're you know you want it it's
just not it's bad yeah the bathroom's
out of order somebody's [ __ ] building
the air conditioning vent up in their
seat you know there's a lot of [ __ ]
diy [ __ ] going on yeah yeah but anyway
he got upset on the bus got off the bus
was wandering around the interstate in
the middle of the night and got hit
by a car oh but it was because he'd
relapsed that was the thing that's when
it's over for a while yeah it's just a
lot of people struggle i think the
separation
i think a lot of people feel that like
what is going on i thought i felt like
our society there was like a thing and
we're all part of something and now a
lot of it feels kind of
supplementary or whatever
supplementary
like um
what does supplementary mean
sullimentary it means like childish and
by yourself kind of oh that feels like
it doesn't make sense it doesn't make
any sense yeah i think that's what i'm
feeling and um
i'm scared baby
i'm scared are you really yeah because i
i mean i've been trying to convince
people
like i had dinner with a friend last
night and i was trying to convince him
i go it'd be okay if i was smoking weed
right
he's like no
i'm like oh okay but if you would have
said it i'd be fine with it i probably
would have done it right
but like i'm getting i tell i've been
telling my therapist last week i go
yeah it's strong desire of drinking and
she's like no
so then it just kind of kind of goes oh
yeah she's right right like it's been
tough the pandemic's been tough i mean
people are [ __ ] overdosing and dying
so it's like
you know like it's been tough it's been
a tough time for me to stay sober i've
had some slips through the pandemic i
went off to that pcs one time remember
you told me oh yeah how long were you
there for i was there for a week eight
days or whatever yeah do you want to get
some did you like it it was really
awesome okay yeah okay good i would go
back i think in january i'm gonna go do
like a 30 day somewhere oh really yeah
just to get out of everything it's just
you know and we're making content all
the time things feel sometimes intense
and exhausting yeah um
[Music]
it's just a hard time and i you know i i
know you and i joke jokes and giggles
and we make things up but it's like it's
good to be able to be easy on yourself
honestly yeah man you're my leader
sometimes man i know when i need help
man and i text you i say hey man i need
some help yeah i know i'm telling you
right now i'm on the fence man yeah i'm
struggling and um
i've been feeling it for a while i think
you know is it some of it angry you feel
like because i feel angry a lot of times
i feel anger yeah i feel anger i also
feel just kind of like
lost i just i can't i can't explain it
and i think that if there was in-house a
meetings and stuff like if i could go to
sundowners on sundays why don't you
they're not they're all zoomed oh
they're all they still aren't yeah and
it's like and it's weird it's like i
can't
for some reason
doing it on zoom like because i start
playing like you know making my video
games on my phone right or like i'll i
remember me and some other comic we were
on that wednesday meeting and we're
telling jokes about people's eyebrows or
whatever
you're mean and we would laugh at like
look at john's eyebrows right now and
then like you know you can do a side
direct message thing on the zoom right
and we'd be giggling it's not real you
know
but um anyway
but you know what i haven't done it yet
and i feel good right now because i'm
with my buddy theo right
sons and daughters
brothers and sisters oh brother brother
sorry i'm not dating daughter i'm not
standing
sons and daughters this is not a
graduation
sorry i scared everyone you know i mean
do we have an unhelpful advice we do
okay go ahead unhopeful boss with bobby
kalila and theovar
uh nosotros would buy it to you you guys
can call me abby
uh here's the quick bobby version uh
before she gives us the full thing i was
molested as a kid now and i'm grown
should i tell my family what happened
some details for context i was molested
as a kid by my next-door neighbor and
yes fat kids